okay everybody let's talk about the
future of the Star Wars franchise this
week saw a few big reports that
Lucasfilm could be put in at standalone
Star Wars movies on hold meaning the
announced Boba Fett movie that was going
to be directed by James Mangold and the
rumored obi-wan kenobe movie might not
be happening however the report said
that Lucasfilm still planned on the Star
Wars trilogies that are in development
there's one by Rian Johnson another
trilogy by Game of Thrones showrunners
David Benioff and DB Weiss Johnson's
producer Ram Bergman said that we could
be seen the first of his new movies as
early as two years from now but when it
comes to these standalone movies solo
director Ron Howard said that the report
about them being put on hold
might not be accurate he shrugged off
the negativity about solo saying it was
still the biggest opening of his career
the question is which Star Wars project
are you guys most looking forward to
like do Star Wars stories need to be
told in trilogy form or can standalone
movies ever be a better option the first
thing is ABC actually when that news was
announced about two hours later came
forward saying that it wasn't true at
all but that's not worth not speculating
over I have theories
obviously Star Wars likes to play a lot
of things safe and I think that solo was
a bit of a risk and it didn't pay off
and the risk wasn't necessarily in terms
of the script or the storyline it was
the fact that they changed directors
halfway through it it was the fact that
you know they're basically focusing on a
character that we've only just seen in
the latest trilogies that we've had I'm
a bit bummed that they didn't kick off
with the obi-wan standalone movie
because you McGregor wanted to play
obi-wan and continue on that role and it
would have been the best way to join and
link the prequels to the current trilogy
it was one of the few things that are
the prequels that people still really
loved he acted the crap out of that role
and he didn't have amazing things to go
on but he made it incredible and I just
think that Star Wars really needed
someone like this and then to hear that
I'm old and Ehrenreich he needed a
little bit of coaching when it came to
acting to try and not mimic Han Solo in
the original by Harrison Ford but to
make his own spin on it so why don't you
just get someone who cannot screw it up
I like the idea of focusing on these new
trilogies not so much that they're new
oh geez but the idea of focusing on new
different things not like hey do you
want to know what Boba Fett was doing no
I really don't I honestly don't care do
you know how Sola became solo I don't
care yeah I'm super ambivalent what's
the Kessel run yeah it's so the idea of
like focusing on stuff like anyway
jumping jumping to different points in
time hopefully different sets of
characters different wait because I
think at least to me the appeal of SAR
was when I was younger is this idea of
limitless possibilities and as the
series has gone on you've realized the
possibilities are actually quite limited
apparently because it's always the same
set of stories yeah that does seem to be
the case at least that's how Disney is
looking at it I think in general the
rule of thumb seems to be trilogies or
franchises as opposed to just standalone
stories and I mean as I we've been
rewatching these Star Wars movies since
the force awakens has come out just the
original Star Wars the 1977 Star Wars
was a standalone movie there was no
expectation to make a sequel out of it
there was some kind of like creative
freedom to Lucas's working and all the
actors work and I'ma be true it's like
we don't know what this is let's just
embrace the weirdness and just kind of
like go with it and when you know we saw
the Death Star blow up for most people
who saw that movie when it came out that
was as far as this universe is gonna go
I I think it is possible to do a
standalone movie that that could work I
think we also run into issues when you
put the trilogy expectations on it that
things will end in a way that's
satisfying like crossing over from the
force awakens to the last Jedi I think
some of the issues we were having with
the last Jedi's it didn't answer all the
questions well it's like yeah you gave
it to two different filmmakers JJ said
Rian Johnson you don't have to answer
these questions do whatever you want
with it and then you kind of set up some
fans to get upset when you know people
take it in another direction or at least
with one movie you just have one
filmmaker in charge of where it's where
the story is gonna go one of the things
that the Marvel does kind of have that
balance where they have they have a
strong show Sean or with with Feige and
so there is even though there there's
that Disney formula that I compared to
that because that's you Disney the same
formula for the princess movies and
everything you use a little bit of
wiggle room to where at least
superficially
dr. strange is 100% different than black
panther mm-hmm yeah and I mean where's
like every Star Wars movie
I think part of it is your freita dwith
the expectation of Star Wars yeah your
and I mean it's like if you were coming
out with like hey here's the new New
Testament everybody's like but let us
know what you think whether you prefer a
standalone version of the future of Star
Wars or if you really prefer these kind
of stories grouped in threes and what do
you think maybe is the difference
between the way these Star Wars
franchises are being rolled out as as
opposed to the other franchises that we
know like Marvel and in the DC movies
but yeah as always make sure to
subscribe to new rock stars for all of
our deep dives into the Star Wars
universe and the other movies that you
love thanks guys